it looks like Ashley Olsen has a new man
in her life the fashion mogul was
recently spotted walking arm-in-arm with
30 year old New York city-based
artist Louie Eisner yep that's ash and
Louie
dressed in sweats taking a cozy morning
stroll in Los Angeles the two were first
seen together at hammer museum's gala in
the garden last October in July the 32
year olds was by Louie's side as he
celebrated his milestone birthday while
Ashley has managed to keep her love life
fairly private there's one relationship
she is opening up about in a new rare
interview with Wall Street Journal
magazine the former child star and her
twin sister Mary Kate got candid about
their personal and business dynamic
ashley explained quote it's been 32
years of learning how to communicate
adding that their sisterly bond is a
marriage and a partnership we have had
ups and downs as for Mary Kate she
dished quote we do everything together
we came out of the womb doing that
[Music]
[Applause]